breaking news und sie sehen schon die
bilder wir schauen gleich live in die
bundespressekonferenz dort der
gesundheitsminister days ministerien
wissen wie geht es weiter mit dem
infektionsschutzgesetz also auf deutsch
wie geht's weiter müssen wir masken
tragen müssen wir vielleicht sogar zb
zwei masken in den flugzeugen tragen
während die politik ganz gemütlich ohne
fliegt wir wollen erklärungen haben wir
wollen antworten haben der korona
fahrplan wie geht es für uns alle weiter
wird jetzt hier dort vorgestellt marco
buschmann und auch unser
gesundheitsminister karl lauterbach
haben jetzt das fortune gedacht
vielen dank ich möchte ich zunächst
einmal ganz herzlich bedanken der weg
zum dass wir hier in ihren
tagen dürfen bedanke mich auch bei ex
minister marco buschmann für die gute
zusammenarbeit in der
vorbereitung dieses gesetzes was dort im
kabinett beschlossen haben das gesetzt
hat eigentlich eine ganz simple aufgabe
wir wollen jetzt kommenden herbst
deutlich besser für die pandemie
gerüstet sein dass das in der
vergangenheit der fall gewesen ist und
ich rechne mit einer deutlichen kroner
welle im herbst aber dass es hier nicht
maßgeblich sondern maßgebliche sollte
eine solche welle kommen müssen wir gut
vorbereitet sein dazu bieten wir
vorbereitungen durch den bund an und wir
ermächtigen die länder möglich mit
möglichkeiten auf die pandemie zu
reagieren
das von uns bereits erwähnte
sieben-punkte-programm muss ich hier
nicht einmal vorstellen aber der siebte
punkt ist eben das
infektionsschutzgesetz und da
ermöglichen wir es den ländern mit einer
masken pflicht mit impfungen mit
obergrenzen im autoinnenraum in einem
stufenplan vorzugehen das ziel dieser
maßnahmen ist dass wir todesfälle
schwere longo vj vorläufig schwere
verläufe aber auch die überlastung der
infrastruktur und die belastungen der
kliniken vermeiden das sind die ziele
der maßnahmen die wir heute beschlossen
und bundesrat soll daher ab dem ersten
jahrzehnten gelten dass also in den fern
und im flugverkehr zwei masken getragen
werden müssen das also in krankenhäusern
und pflegeeinrichtungen
die schutzniveaus erhöht werden dass
dort der beispiel zwei masken sich geht
und darüber hinaus getestet wird also im
vergleich zum letzten jahr erhöhen wir
dort die auf schutzmaßnahmen noch einmal
war die also derzeit also kursierende
omikron die a5 variante ansteckender ist
als varianten die wir im letzten jahr
gehabt haben darüber hinaus also
ermöglichen wir es den ländern in zwei
stufen auf die pandemie entwicklung zu
reagieren
zunächst einmal also in der stufe 1 ab
dem 1 zehnter ist es den ländern dann
also in abhängigkeit von der entwicklung
der fallzahlen und der gesamtschau der
pandemie möglich ohne masken pflicht für
die innenräume
also zuvor zu sehen wenn man dass solche
masken pflicht vorgesehen ist dann
müssen die länder auch die ausnahme
einer testung ermöglichen das heißt
derjenige der dann getestet ist ersten
der masken pflicht befreit aber die
masken sicht kann eingeführt werden wird
sie eingeführt dann ist diese
ermöglichung einer also testung dort wo
das möglich ist vorzusehen durch die
länder darüber hinaus haben wir an der
regelung verändert im vergleich zu den
ihnen vorliegenden entwurf von vor
wenigen wochen und zwar haben wir die
möglichkeit das also in den innenräumen
von der test von der testung also
abstand genommen wird und die masken
schicht also abgegolten wird durch eine
frische impfung oder durch eine frische
genesung diese regeln halten wir
weiterhin für sinnvoll die machen wir
aber jetzt als kann regelungen für die
länder das heißt die länder können die
masken pflicht in den innenräumen
vorsehen und können dann also im rahmen
dieser masken pflicht diejenigen die
frisch geimpft sind oder völlig genesen
sind und das sind jeweils also
diejenigen die vor drei monaten
spätestens geimpft worden sind oder
genießen sind von der masken pflicht
befreien somit um es einfach zu machen
wenn die masken pflicht kommt weil das
paar nie geschehen ist es notwendig
macht von den ländern beschlossen dann
kann der test als eine alternative zur
maske gesehen werden die länder können
es aber auch ermöglichen dass
stattdessen eine fläche impfung oder
eine fläche genesung geht wir wollen das
vereinfachen indem wir die korona waren
erst am grünen kennzeichnen ich werde
meine krawatte nicht noch einmal hoch
halten weil sie belehrt haben sie alles
schon gesehen und
somit also ist diese regelung also
fortgesetzt worden das eine kann
regelung der länder also vorgesehen
worden darüber hinaus haben natürlich
also die veranstalter wie auch die also
gastronomie wie auch also die bars cafés
und restaurants die haben die
möglichkeit also mit vom hausrecht
gebrauch zu machen die können dann zum
beispiel ihre einrichtungen also so
führen dass man entweder nur mit einer
maske zutritt hat und dann nur mit einem
test oder beispielsweise mit einem test
oder einer frischen impfung oder einer
frischen genesung das sind die regeln
die ab dem 1 durch die regierungen der
länder ermöglicht werden können wenn die
pandemie das notwendig macht die
fallzahlen steigern die künftige
infrastruktur ist bedroht der pandemie
radar zeigt also also ein dynamisches
infektionsgeschehen wir haben viele tote
oder wir haben viele schwere verläufe
dann können die länder in der
gesamtschau dieser kriterien eine zweite
stufe hier zünden und diese zweite stufe
würden vorsehen dass die masken pflicht
im innenraum grundsätzlich gilt dass es
dann keine ausnahmen mehr gibt für
getestete durch genießen oder sich
geimpfte das kann dann auch vorgesehen
werden dass in den innenräumen wie auch
draußen
stans gebote gelten das kann dann auch
vorgesehen seien das also obergrenzen
für die innenräume gelten sodass also zb
in den restaurants oder in den cafés
oder aber in den also vor der
veranstaltung nur eine bestimmte zahl
von personen zutritt hat so dass wir
dann quasi noch einmal nachlegen können
durch die aufregung die über geschlossen
ab insgesamt glaube ich dass ein gutes
instrumental und wir haben also masken
pflicht wir haben impfungen dann platzt
wir haben zwischen der genesenen
ausweise wir haben testungen an platz
wir haben sogar die möglichkeit aus die
masken pflicht in den außenräumen
vorzugeben wenn also in dieser zweiten
stufe das notwendig ist wir haben die
möglichkeit dass also die ausnahmen für
die innenraum massen pflicht aufgehoben
wird und wir können den obergrenzen
einführen also ein breites
instrumentarium
ich hoffe nicht dass es in der gänze
eingesetzt werden muss aber es muss
eingesetzt werden können und darauf
haben wir uns für stadt verständigt
schließlich wir haben uns auch darauf
verständigt dass es einen weiteren
lockdown oder schulschließungen nicht
geben wird in den schulen ist vorgesehen
dass masken vorgegeben werden können ab
der fünften klasse in den kitas und in
den grundschulen können auch testungen
vorgegeben werden aber von
schulschließungen oder schließung und
andere art und lockt an regelungen haben
wir abstand genommen meine vielen dank
und herr minister dr schwankte ja ganz
herzlichen dank auch ich bedanke mich
für die gastfreundschaft und dass wir
hier ein gutes moderates und maßvolles
konzept vorgelegt haben in der
rollenverteilung ist es natürlich so der
gesundheitsminister kümmert sich um die
gesundheit und der justizminister
kümmert sich um die frage ob die
verfahren die verhältnismäßigkeit und
auch den grundrechtsschutz ausreichend
ausreichend gewährleistet ist ich will
einmal was zum verfahren sagen ich
glaube dass wir ein hohes maß an
transparenz in diesem verfahren und auch
an qualitätssicherung gewährleistet
haben vielleicht noch nie in der
pandemie denn wir haben uns ja exakt an
den fahrplan gehalten den wir auch schon
im frühjahr angekündigt haben da gab es
ja die sunset klausel für die maßnahmen
wir hatten im gesetz den termin zu dem
der evaluierungsbericht uns vorliegt und
diese termine waren auch so angeordnet
dass dazwischen beratungen in der
regierung stattfinden konnten beratung
mit den ländern stattfinden konnten und
jetzt auch ein reguläres
gesetzgebungsverfahren im september im
bundestag stattfinden kann ich glaube
das ist erstmal ein gewinn weil dadurch
gewährleistet war dass diese ideen und
vorschläge natürlich ganz anders
rückgekoppelt werden können auch wir
haben ja unseren ersten vorschlag vor
drei wochen schon der öffentlichkeit
präsentiert und auch in diesem
zusammenhang gab es rückmeldungen
kommentierung auch aus den ländern aus
der wissenschaft auf die man eingehen
konnte also ich glaube ein so hohes maß
an transparenz an planbarkeit auch an
konsultationsprozesses hat es noch nicht
gegeben und das ist ein stück verfahrens
klugheit ist meine erste bemerkung die
zweite bemerkung ist natürlich die wenn
es um die frage geht maßnahmen brauchen
wir das überhaupt und ich weiß es gibt
gerade in der jetzigen stimmung wo wir
eine sehr stabile lage haben im moment
so das gefühl kann dieser ganze mist
nicht einfach vorbei sein und offen
gestehen ich würde mir das auch am
liebsten wünschen aber das virus ist
eben nicht weg und wir bereiten uns ja
nicht auf eine lage vor für den fall
dass alles so bleibt wie es jetzt ist
sondern wir müssen uns vorbereiten auf
eine lage wie sie mutmaßlich sagen wir
im herbst winter eintreten kann und zwar
nach anna auch kritischer
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
und die sagen uns dass eine lage
eintreten kann dass wir eben noch mal in
eine schwierige situation geraten auf
die muss man sich formal warum ist
dieses paket maß voll das einzige was ja
wir für den herbst winter über das
hinaus was bekannt ist qualitativ
wirklich als bundesgesetzgeber
einheitlich anordnen sind ja die höheren
sicherheitsstandards in den
krankenhäusern und ein altenpflegeheim
und das halte ich auch für absolut
richtig und geboten denn dort haben wir
sehr viele menschen die wohl ne rabl
sind für die also auch eine relevantes
sterblichkeitsrisiko besteht und diese
maßnahme gibt es auch in anderen
europäischen ländern teilweise wurden
sie dort sogar im sommer durchgehalten
und deshalb ist das eine vernünftige und
auch angemessene maßnahme um hier
besonders schutzwürdigen gruppen einen
angemessenen schutz zu bieten wir haben
leider die erfahrung in den anderen
quellen machen müssen insbesondere im
herbst und winter dass wir eben dort
besonders viele opfer zu beklagen haben
deshalb muss man etwas tun alles andere
was wir vor sehen sind ja reine
rechtsgrundlagen also optionen die die
länder ziehen können aber nicht müssen
und ich will auch noch mal was dazu
sagen weil er solche gesetzestexte
manchmal auch sehr
munter und kreativ interpretiert werden
was da geschrieben es ist der maximale
rahmen bis zu dem man gehen kann die
länder können aber immer auch wenig
weniger machen also sie müssen davon
nicht gebrauch machen sie können bei
masken in rom beispielsweise vom können
sie gebrauch machen können das aber auch
abschied ihr tun also sie können
bestimmte branchen aus nehmen sie können
bestimmte institutionen aus nehmen das
haben wir in der begründung auch noch
mal klargestellt körper herr
dienstleistung aber ein bundesland
könnte auch sagen ich mache masken
pflicht zb bei behörden weil da alle
menschen hingehen müssen ja weil da auch
wohl hingehen müssen ich nehme aber die
gastronomie oder die hochschulen oder so
aus dass geht also als ein hoch
flexibles instrument mit dem man der
lage vor ort gerecht wird wir haben
besonders lange gerungen es ist auch
kein geheimnis aber sind da glaube ich
zu einem sehr ordentlichen guten
kompromiss gekommen bei den schulen denn
das will ich hier sagen die schülerinnen
und schüler waren sicherlich die gruppe
die am meisten in der pandemie gelitten
haben und
ich will jetzt gar nicht zu sehr zurück
blicken aber dieser gruppe haben wir
wirklich am meisten zugemutet
insbesondere was die ausübung ihres
rechts auf bildung angeht insbesondere
was die schulschließung angeht und
deshalb bin ich auch froh dass wir uns
zügig darauf einigen konnten dass die
das instrument der schulschließung also
völlig unverhältnismäßig ist und dass
wir auch beim instrument der maske eben
hier die jungen schülerinnen und schüler
die kinder raus nehmen bis zur klasse 4
und ansonsten folgende regel gilt ab
klasse 5 können die bundesländer ja auch
nicht einfach sagen zur allgemeinen
pandemie abwehr mache ich jetzt maske an
den schulen sondern dort ist ja der
gedanke der im gesetz steht wenn die
alternative wäre dass ansonsten
beispielsweise durch hohe zahl von
krankheitsfällen in den lehrerkollegien
kein präsenzunterricht mehr aufrecht
erhalten kann und wir ansonsten die
ganze klassen und jahrgänge nach hause
schicken müssen dann ist es doch besser
mit medizinischer maske
präsenzunterricht anbieten zu können als
keinen präsenzunterricht anbieten zu
können und ich glaube das ist eine
vernünftige regelung und dann war
zwischenzeitlich in der diskussion mit
den ländern noch immer unklar ist das
wirklich eine harte rechtliche
voraussetzungen es in der begründung
noch einmal klar gestellt also dieser
gedanke gilt
ansonsten will ich auch noch mal was zu
der zweiten stufe sagen die kollege
lauterbach erwähnt hat auch hier ging es
natürlich darum einen hohen
rechtsstaatlichen standard zu wahren und
dieses zweite fach des werkzeugkastens
ist ja durch zwei vorhängeschlössern
gesichert dass eine vorhängeschloss ist
natürlich die demokratische legitimation
durch einen landtagsbeschluss
und das zweite vorhängeschloss ist
natürlich etwas was sie schon kennen aus
der jetzigen rechtslage dass die
bundesländer eine konkrete gefahr für
die kritische infrastruktur dann dort
auch feststellen müssen dass ist ein
gefahrenabwehr rechtlich bekannter
begriff damit wissen wir wussten auch
was anzufangen und der ist auch
gerichtlich überprüfbar und selbst wenn
das der fall ist haben wir auf der
rechtsfolgen seite sehr maßvolle
maßnahmen wir haben auch einige
instrumente gegenüber der jetzigen
rechtslage sogar aus dem werkzeugkasten
rausgenommen sie alle kennen die 2g 3g
zugangsbeschränkungen die die alte
hotspot regelungen vorsieht die haben
wir herausgenommen weil die auch
wirklich sehr umstritten war und vom
evaluierungs gremium auch als nicht sehr
zweckmäßig empfunden wurde also auch
dort haben wir
maßvolle regeln und
insbesondere das thema masken im
außenbereich das ist ja viel diskutiert
worden es ist ja nicht maske im
außenbereich sondern ist maske bei
veranstaltungen also wir reden nicht
über die einkaufsstraße
sondern es ist maske bei veranstaltungen
die draußen stattfinden wenn die
anderthalb metern nicht eingehalten
werden können also auch da haben wir den
anwendungsbereich auf die wirklich
relevanten fälle so begrenzt so dass
sich insgesamt sagen möchte in
anbetracht der tatsache dass wir uns
vorbereiten müssen haben wir hier den
bundesländern ein paket an die hand
gegeben sehr maßvoller regelung die auch
wenn wir uns in europa umschauen sich
maßvoll verhalten also die immer wieder
gehörte behauptung deutschland sei hier
also als geisterfahrer unterwegs oder
niemand würde das tun das entspricht
nicht der tatsache viele länder haben
entweder noch permanente regelung die
teilweise sehr viel schärfere
grundrechtseingriffe ermöglichen und
viele europäischen also da gehen wir
einmal raus als einigermaßen stolz auf
den neuen chor oder fahrplan der
bundesregierung der marco buschmann der
bundesjustizminister derselbe der dort
genau in der bundespressekonferenz saß
paar monate ist es erst her und gesagt
hat ende märz mit dem frühjahr dieses
jahres enden alle corona maßnahmen jetzt
regiert das sieht ganz anders aus ganz
genau auf was man einmal zusammen was da
alles auf uns zukommt im herbst werde
gesundheitsminister sagte er rechne mit
einer wirklich groß mit einer starken
welle für den herbst ist sagt er eben
gerade dort in der pressekonferenz was
kommt die massen pflicht kommt fdp 2 a
mask mehr in das flugzeugen das ist
beschlossene sache auch wenn wir vor
wenigen momenten und auch gestern noch
den kanzler und vizekanzler gesehen
haben im regierungsflieger ohne maske
für uns heißt das sp2 maske und dann
dann wird's kompliziert denn dann ist es
so ein bisschen ländersache und man
blickt nicht so richtig ab wann diese
maßnahmen greifen das wird besonders
schwierig wenn sie ins restaurant wählen
wollen das ist dann wirklich in jedem
bundesland anders aber klar ist die
maske kommt die schulen sollen offen
bleiben das hat man gerade betont soll
also kein lockdown mehr geben dass es
die nachricht sie raushauen wollen in
die welt kein lockdown geben und keine
schulschließungen geben dennoch haben
die länder viele instrumente an die hand
bekommen mit der sie mit denen sie ein
grund den sound den dies alles trägt den
hat karl lauterbach vorgegeben mit dem
satz er rechnet mit einer großen herbst
welle
[Musik]